I mean I I agree like with that if you  want your kid to live a certain type of  Lifestyle you absolutely have to make a  certain amount of money but but the  truth is that every girl can't get a guy  that's that rich so you have to figure  out a way to make it work you gotta get  BBL  well not you but like in general that  seems to be the plan for most of these  girls when I go to the club in Miami I'm  like these [ __ ] just get bbls and  just stand around  and just hope some dude's gonna be hyped  on them it's like the weirdest most  transparent [ __ ] Dynamic on Earth  it must work if they're doing it  yeah and like to some extent I mean  maybe it's just attention and not like  getting an actual ring but but attention  is step one yeah